and finally new rule you can't be in
charge of counting the votes if you
think the votes from one of the parties
don't exist
normally in a democracy this is not
something you'd have to say but let me
introduce you to Mark fincham he is the
Republican nominee for a secretary of
state in Arizona and I'm guessing the
bartender at an okay Corral theme park
if he wins it'll be his job to count the
vote next time and Mark not only
believes Trump won the 2020 election he
literally can't conceive that Biden
could have
why he says I can't find anyone who will
admit that they voted for Joe Biden
yeah forget the meticulous audits the
hand recounts the independent
verifications run by Republican
officials this guy has never personally
met a Biden voter so they don't exist
you know I've never been to a BTS
concert but I believe K-pop exists
[Applause]
and I gotta say more than anything this
is what is wrong with this country a
real division isn't between red and blue
it's between the people on both sides
who aren't willing to mingle with
Americans outside their political tribe
and so I have no idea what they're
really like
and the people on both sides who are
willing to do that of course Mark
fincham never met a Biden voter and
probably things Democrats eat babies
because every
because everybody he knows voted for
Trump
because he never leaves his hermetically
sealed right-wing Panic Room
and I could say the same of many
liberals who would never even talk to a
trump voter I asked a friend of mine
recently if he wanted to come to a
little party I was having and when he
found out one of the guests had voted
for Trump he told me he wasn't coming
because quote I wouldn't breathe the
same air
okay there's a word for people like this
[ __ ]
[Applause]
when we confine ourselves to Bubbles
alternate points of view become not just
objectionable they're unfathomable this
guy fincham thinks Biden voters are
literally affection like Wizards or the
female orgasm
[Laughter]
when he was pressed on this and asked
isn't it possible that lots of people
you don't know personally did vote for
Biden he replied in a fantasy world
anything's possible
thank you
Mark have you ever been to a Whole Foods
or talked to a woman under 50.
you know in a nation based on pluralism
it's very dangerous that Americans are
so in our silos and it's largely because
we've stopped living amongst each other
the latest Census Data revealed that
Americans have hit the lowest rate of
moving since they started tracking it in
1947 and while some of that is economic
much of the reason Americans don't move
anymore is they just wouldn't feel
welcome in too many places in their own
country would anyone ride the New York
City subway wearing a Maga hat foreign
would anyone go to a NASCAR race in a
Biden t-shirt while they chant [ __ ] Joe
Biden
that's where we are now where other
parts of the country are seen as scary
no-go zones America's like a prison now
where the inmates think they need to
join one of the gangs to survive and we
dare not walk on the wrong side of the
yard
in January 2021 the New York Times
published the headline they can't leave
the Bay Area fast enough and followed it
up that July with the headline Tech
workers who swore off the Bay Area are
coming back
yeah they saw all the red hats and were
like [ __ ] this I'll take the wildfires
thank you
and the same would be true if an
Evangelical preacher showed up in West
Hollywood
once he was done blowing all those guys
he would hate it